we really are at a point now where we
can't cope with what it is that we were
expected to deal with sickness and
mental health problems amongst my
colleagues are rife really and you know
we've got examples and I know of police
officers who've been conveyed to
hospital from work because they've had a
meltdown
I'm aware of instances where sergeant's
on our public protection units are
allocating work on the basis of who's
the least tearful that morning when they
get to work in the last sort of 15
months or so the Police Federation in
West Midlands and refer just over 80
people to the the National Police
Federation welfare support program and
those are people who are there
undergoing a significant mental health
crisis they're experiencing suicidal
thoughts and tendencies and they are at
risk of doing something really serious
to hurt themselves this is only as a
result of the pressures that they've
been put under and you know everybody
keeps here in the crime state and
everything crimes knocked down crime is
not down at all you know we haven't got
enough officers to do what's being
expected on us The Times come to say you
know enough really easy enough you know
we need some proper investments in
placing we need a proper recruitment
program and we need strong resources in
the way that we all know it should be
resourced I investigate homicides
suspicious deaths it's difficult and
traumatic work um you know when I join
the police I understood that all would
be tested on occasion test it to the
point where on who knows what's going to
happen I think everybody accepts that
when they join the place but this is
something completely different is in
that there is no downtime in between
these critical incidents these critical
complex heartbreaking investigations the
public suffer as a result don't they you
know we need police officers to be at
the top of their game we don't need
tired broken people trying to do their
best with equally broken people you know
it is a recipe for disaster if we're
going to properly be able to protect the
public and do what what they expect of
us we need some boots on the ground
really certainly more world homicide
investigation you know we rely a lot on
intelligence quite often and what we're
finding now when we're getting cases is
that our intelligence he's starting to
drop in about 2014 because we haven't
got officers out in communities being
proactive talking to people turning
people over and dealing
low-level criminality you know there's
all sorts of intelligence that we can
glean from dealing with people are
involving that kind of thing and we just
not got the opportunity to do it and I
do worry that actually the key to
resolving a lot of these issues is
through the proper collection and use of
intelligence and we're not providing
ourselves with the opportunity of doing
that you know we've got response
officers who are you know going from job
to job to job to job they're not having
a chance to resolve the incident that
are at before they've been cleared by
the controller to go to the next
emergency and we haven't got an option
to say to somebody who's been beaten up
or held at knifepoint or something well
actually we haven't got anybody to send
I always wanted to be a police officer
I'm proud to be a police officer I'm
really proud to represent whispers
please I've had more moments when I've
considered whether this really is the
career to me because you know I've got a
family and I've got other people to
consider as well there's a lot of us
that we want to stick it out this is
what we signed up to do you know we want
to serve the public we want to do what's
right we want to do what the public
expect of us but I think for people
coming into it who perhaps aren't as
settled in the role you know that they
will be looking to get an act certainly
a lot of my colleagues that I speak to
you know are actively seeking
alternative employment last week when
Oliver was 570 police officers in place
place stuff off sick in West Midlands
place over a third of those with
stress-related or mental health issues
as a result of the job you don't need to
be a doctor to work out that actually
that that figure is likely to be a lot
higher isn't it because people we
experiencing all sorts of other health
issues which actually are attributable
to the stress that they're under